for germany it's the end of an era
and as europe's biggest economy there
are some huge challenges ahead
from its increasingly complex
relationship with china to climate
change
all eyes will be on how germany's new
leaders grapple with these issues
but there's one german industry that
reveals a lot about the country's
prospects
it's cars
traditionally the car industry here has
been very powerful there have been open
doors to german ministries to the
chancellory
germany's car industry is a vital part
of its economy with links to government
that go back decades
how this world-renowned motor industry
navigates the challenges ahead could
tell you more than you think about
germany's future
[Music]
the curves the precision
it's cutting-edge engineering like this
that has helped place car makers at the
heart of the german economy
and the industry has proved a bellwether
for the country's future prospects too
since the 70s car exports have risen
with germany's wealth and influence
manufacturing is incredibly important in
germany it represents around 18 percent
of gdp and of course the car sector
represents a very large part of that
it's not quite you know where the car
industry goes germany goes but the
sector is absolutely crucial to the
future of germany and the future of its
industrial model
but that industrial model could be under
threat
after over half a century of global
dominance german car makers are now
playing catch-up
and it's not just the car industry
that's losing ground
[Music]
in 2000 seven of the world's most
valuable companies were german
but in the past two decades that number
has fallen to just three
how germany's car makers attempt to claw
back global market share could be
telling for the economy as a whole
[Music]
take international relations
almost half of germany's gdp comes from
exports
cars make up the biggest proportion of
this
who germany sells cars to matters
it can point to alliances
or trouble brewing
since 2016 china has been germany's
biggest trading partner
[Music]
in 1998 german trade with china was
worth 16 billion dollars
now it's worth over 180 billion
but there's a fear that germany could
have become too reliant on the chinese
market
for the past 16 years angela merkel has
courted china in the name of trade
it's an approach that has its risks
particularly now we're in this context
of this emerging systemic competition
between america and china at least for
some people there's a worry for putting
all of your eggs into the chinese basket
might leave you exposed to some of the
ill winds of geopolitics and
geoeconomics that might be heading
germany and europe's way in the coming
years
there is a strong sense that germany's
china policy is going to have to be
recalibrated basically on pretty much
every single front
germany's new leader will face the same
challenge as its car industry
how to keep their biggest trading
partner on side
without ending up in its pocket
china already leads germany in one
crucial aspect of manufacturing
digitalization
this is not traditionally a country that
has been closely associated with digital
innovation it's going to be a big
challenge across the whole range of
domains we look at car makers and it's
you know traditionally engineers have
been at the heart of what it is that car
manufacturers do making components
fitting them together making them look
beautiful
the digital skill set has traditionally
taken a back seat and that's going to
have to change
and it's not just germany's car industry
that needs to modernize
before the pandemic two-thirds of german
businesses said they still regularly
used a fax machine
and only one in three german companies
have a central digital strategy
just eight years ago angela merkel
became a meme when she referred to the
internet as noiland
the german for unchartered territory
the next government is probably going to
have to be a lot more digitally literate
than the ones that angela merkel has led
for the last 16 years and it's going to
have to do a hell of a lot more to
translate the rhetoric on digitalization
into the reality of fostering genuine
change in this country which has been
severely lacking for the last couple of
decades
but there's an even greater challenge
that could define germany's global
relevance
climate change
here germany's car industry is a
microcosm for how the country will need
to radically shift
traditional forms of power will need to
be replaced
for cars that means a race to go
electric
mobility
is a great consensus
oliver zipsa took over as ceo of bmw in
2019
he's overseeing one of the biggest
shifts in the company's history
a commitment to battery-powered cars
the whole car industry is launching a
lot of electric vehicles now and bmw is
on the forefront of that i think we need
to speed up our efforts to keep up with
the electric mobility demand it's a big
market developing of course we want to
increase our profitability and with the
right set of components products i think
that can be a very solid business
foundation
climate change has forced this shift to
a greener future but it was american not
german engineering that first realized
it
an electric car can be the best car in
the world
although an early investor in electric
technology bmw has now fallen behind
rivals in the e-car market
other german car makers were slower
still
when it comes to fostering innovation
the country is still in second gear
[Music]
although disruptive innovation does
exist here germany's leaders could do
more to nurture it
let's see the acceleration right
that's good
sono motors is a startup based in munich
they're technically car makers but their
approach is light years away from the
traditional brands
what we are doing is we producing an
electric vehicle that is equipped with
solar cells
[Music]
they're one of several developers around
the world trying to get a solar powered
vehicle to market
their car the scion can share power with
the grid and other cars
and comes with ride sharing software
built in
[Music]
their claim is that they're the only car
company that thinks the industry should
be selling fewer cars
their approach could upend the industry
and their ethos is emblematic of a new
way of german thinking
we see ourselves as a mobility service
provider it's not only about the car
it's about the whole new mobility
concept we're providing caching ride
sharing power sharing
a car itself solar integration solar
technology we sell to others
there's a whole new approach on how we
think mobility should look like in the
future
small companies like sono have the
vision for a greener future but
germany's politics may make it hard to
realize
one of the challenges i think that
you're going to see in germany is that
the next coalition is probably going to
be made up of three different parties
that may well have very different ideas
about how to manage the climate
transition the sort of
consensus-oriented approach that's
deeply ingrained in germany may not look
like it is particularly well suited to
manage this extraordinary industrial
transition that we're going to have to
bring about in the years ahead so that's
going to mean a very very big role to
the next chancellor
and as efforts to digitize continue
germany's new leader should plan for a
workforce in need of upskilling
[Music]
we're going to have a massive ramp up of
jobs in the battery manufacturing sector
we're going to have a huge demand for
coders sort of digital skills and
competent decline in the demand for
engineering skills that we've seen
and as china's mic grows germany will
have to be more careful about who it
gets into bed with
one of the things i think for example
that you're going to see in the next
legislative period is real investment in
europe's ability to stand on its own two
feet to ensure that it is not
excessively exposed to the risks that
could come from a stepping up of the
strategic competition between america
and china angela merkel was careful not
to scare voters with talk of
transformation but that's left germany's
new leaders with a lot to do
germany has to do better
right we have those very big companies
those very big players here but they
aren't the disrupter the driver behind
innovation disruption comes always from
new young companies which drive change
german startups rarely grow into tech
giants
without making changes germany risks
losing competitiveness throughout its
economy
there's a nice german word zuccumbed
feyer kite which is roughly translated
as the ability to face the future
a lot of people looking at these
challenges of starting to wonder how the
const fake germany really is and this
really is going to be a big challenge
not only for the next chancellor but for
the government that he or she is going
to lead because a lot of people think
that germany isn't really ready and that
it will need to act quite quickly across
a whole range of domains in order to
meet these challenges head on
thanks for watching
to read the economist's assessment of
germany's future after angela merkel
click the link and don't forget to
subscribe
you